[Musique]
dans une ambiance familiale
un petit groupe prépare les paniers de
la semaine chez cadet roussel en plein
coeur de la montérégie la petite ferme
bio a été l'une des premières il ya 25
ans a distribué des paniers de fruits et
légumes à ses abonnés les temps changent
et 145 ferme le ont désormais au québec
soit 13 de plus que l'an dernier et
elles sont une vingtaine comme cadet
roussel a livré des paniers même en
hiver on doit cultiver les légumes
pendant l'été vous faire des grosses
récoltes à l'automne stocker les légumes
dans des frigos puis ensuite on a des
légumes frais quasi de verdure diverses
c'est comme un nouveau si au québec de
deux lacs la connaissance de faire faire
des cultures en tunnel froid des
cultures dans chauffer dans cette serre
par exemple anne roussel fait pousser
des épinards et du mesclun cet hiver sa
ferme distribuer ses fruits et légumes
bio donc sans pesticides à 420 personnes
emeline dalmas ont fait partie on l'a
rencontré à montréal
un des points de distribution ou cadet
roussel fait ses livraisons elle est
abonnée aux paniers bio depuis sept ans
premier truc c'était c'est de me dire
que l'argent va directement à
l'agriculteur c'est lui qui peut vivre
avec il ya pas d intermédiaire qui fait
que l'acteur lui a plus d'argent à la
fin les produits sont bien meilleurs
sont super bons après personnellement
j'ai pas une passion pour aller faire
mes courses dans une épicerie la
pandémie l'a conforté dans son choix et
elle en a aussi incité bien d'autres à
s'abonner au panier l'appel du québec à
acheter local s'est vite fait sentir
là on a constaté une hausse de 46 % des
abonnements qui nous donne un total de
28 mille familles en cette année on se
rend compte que les gens sera bonne
rapidement et massivement la campagne et
et 2021 du réseau des fermiers de
famille est lancée aujourd'hui est déjà
plus de 60 % des places sont réservées
du jamais vu c'est plate à dire mais la
pandémie a été une bonne chose pour nous
je pense que la pandémie à reconnecter
les gens avec l'essentiel
donc c'est un juste retour des choses de
connaître la personne qui fait pousser
nos légumes de s'alimenter de façon
biologique dans le respect de
l'environnement pour notre santé on les
appelle les abonnés coville succès qui
arrive jusqu'aux vide là et il ya comme
une urgence un besoin urgent que c'est
génial de forêt répondre en même temps
il faut continuer l'éducation qui va
avec ça de bon oui là le panier arrivent
chaque semaine faut pas gaspiller
légumes faut cuisiner il faut apprendre
de nouvelles recettes faut oser anne
roussel veut conserver une qualité de
vie et elle a fixé à 450 sa limite de
clients hebdomadaire pour l'été qui
vient l'an dernier 250 personnes étaient
sur ses listes d'attentes
nous on a la chance d'avoir une personne
bénévole qui s'occupe de nos
inscriptions à notre ferme pierre à ce
moment a fait presque du 40 heures
semaine de gérer les questions répondre
aux appels aux courriels pour les
abonnements des paniers
cadet rousselle cultive soixante dix
fruits et légumes différents
ces abonnements reviennent en moyenne
afin de 33 au 44 dollar par semaine
selon la grosseur du panier de ce sont
les gens doivent comparer avec ce qu'ils
achèteraient en légumes bio à l'épicerie
que saidal j.dray entre 7 et 9 et n 1
dans le panier
j'avoue que ces derniers temps d'un
quand on a commencé à s'inquiéter avec
l'augmentation des prix moi mon pagne
été payés à l'avancé et donc ça a pas
bougé
donc c'est aussi un avantage mine de
rien
selon le réseau des fermiers de famille
le prix médian du panier bio québec est
passé de 28 dollars 50 en 2020 à 30
dollars cette année
ici jean sébastien cloutier radio-canada
mont saint grégoire